[Musik]
willkommen zur fortsetzung folgt durch
den stadtgarten rätsel mit geschichte wo
früherer reporter oder dokfilm und wie
es weitergegangen sind mit gott zum
alkohol jugendliche die mehr vernünftig
sie versteht sieht sich ruß in der mode
und natürlich bringt das gehört
irgendwie zur problem wir zu allerdings
denn wenn der auch roh zu ihrem lachen
haupt wird grundriss steiner hat als
jugendliche sehr schwierig führt mit 14
trinken mit 15 ist alkoholabhängig und
noch am abgrund der
als der junge andere ist das funkige
porträtiert
einmal über den durst trinken ist eines
schlimm wird es wenn der alkoholkonsum
zu einem täglichen muss wird wie für den
17-jährigen anderes wegen
schulschwierigkeiten und diversen
kleinen delikten ist er in einem
erziehungsheim gelandet nach seinem
dritten alkoholentzug soll ihn der
aufenthalt bei einer bauernfamilie im
kanton aargau wieder boden unter den
füßen verschaffen
[Musik]
schon sein vater war alkoholiker gewesen
trank regelmäßig bier und ging im suff
jeweils auf die mutter von andreas loos
als sich die eltern scheiden ließen war
der kleine bub zwölf jahre alt mit 14
fing anderes sein fatales spiel mit dem
alkohol an
was ich am liebsten
[Musik]
mache ja auch gut so hat das doch na ja
schon lustig mit planung und
[Musik]
prof eine flasche schnaps und aufhausen
dass bene ja die sind einfach unter
verschluss und
die flasche warf eine bierflasche die
wäre der reisbauer sie sind auch zählt
großer zettel ericsson wie viel das sein
zu machen themen schwele nach dem
absetzen da ist klar das thema problem
ab und zu darf anderes am wochenende
heim zu seiner alleinerziehenden mutter
heim an den ort schlechte erinnerungen
[Musik]
eine frisur wie ein marsmensch anderes
wehrt sich gegen das erwachsenwerden mit
seinen mitteln
protzigen berner oberland talgrund
steilen berg züge links und rechts
15 weizen kein kino
freunde hat andres kaum mehr im dorf der
alkohol war das einzige was ihn mit
seinen kumpels von damals verbunden
hatte
[Musik]
wie wurde anderes zum alkoholiker
mutter steine verdient ihr geld an der
coop kasse neben dem haushalt bleibt da
wenig zeit für die kinder
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
das
gefühl dass sie
irgendwie vertrag
einfach denke das macht doch deine
den rocking muskeln von bibi aisha
al-gaddafi
menschen ums leben gekommen ich habe
schon weg soll ich deswegen auch
sonnabend gegen sachlich wenn ich
das
tue
ich
habe das nicht schmeckt und martin die
sie zusammen mit
mit
immowelt.de
sowie solid 5
was ist weg
[Musik]
warum ist aus dem kleinen andres nicht
ein ganz normaler jugendlicher geworden
was hätte er gebraucht um nicht auf die
schiefe bahn zu kommen
[Musik]
mit 15 trank anderes täglich eine
flasche jack daniels er kaufte seinen
whisky meistens im denner frutigen für
günstige 26 franken niemand aus der
näheren umgebung nahm sein abrutschen
zur kenntnis ahnte was in ihm vorging
stellte den jungen burschen zur rede
[Musik]
hinter den rangier geleisen hat anderes
mit seinen kollegen viel zeit verbracht
ja
franken
cannabis group
verwendeten sonnig
selbermachen
samstag für den
absturz
war abgestürzt
ja ich muss das jetzt also
abgestürzt
kaufen mehr zum
zug kommen aber die plätze so denkt
macht und du mir aber
holen was sie bekommen
ich glaube
[Musik]
ich habe das selber zu
sein scheint ob sich das negative die
andere ist spürt nach wie vor die
verlockung sich durch alkohol aus der
realen welt zu beamen
[Musik]
do
die letzte
unter dem motto auf der infa schon mal
darauf fahren
hast du doch
ja
und jetzt hier eigentlich auszeichnet
sich
auch die aktien ich finde ja schon
[Applaus]
[Musik]
einmal
wenn es kommen
ehemalige abstellen
meint es funktioniert
ich habe mit dem viel später
[Musik]
jugendliche können hier unter schlecht
abschätzen wie viel alkohol sie
vertragen markus wolschlager von der
sanität basel stadt hat in den warmen
sommernächten viel zu tun
das wird immer wieder jugend wasser
22 jährig 14-jährige sie so schön besser
das alter 14 der 15 bis
17 18 je nachdem ob dieser tendenz so
14-jährige und vor allem leiter und das
stehe schon länger fest juni mal so viel
wie üblich
personen mit snowboards und denn was sie
natürlich jetzt neue zu trinken sind
harte sachen also könnten irgendwer
tobacco eine flasche wodka organisiere
wo sie vor einer älteren das geholfen
oder sich irgendwie mit wodka moderieren
alkopops und trinken sind natürlich mit
dem wort gehalten einmal acht fälle
alkohol oder den fünf jahre mit diesem
starken monats wieder über pierre und je
nach damals alles dazu
noch nicht
sanitäter alltag um 1 uhr in der nacht
muss eine 17-jährige auf die
notfallstation gebracht werden ihr
schönes ausgeh kleid ist verkauft viel
zu hastig hat sie die süßen drinks in
sich hineingeschüttet ein alkoholexzess
kann schlimm enden wenn die atmung oder
das herz nicht mehr mitmachen deshalb
müssen die jugendlichen patienten
während der ganzen nacht im spital
überwacht werden
das mini jungen
auf der straße behangen und alkohol
konsumieren
[Musik]
das geld jetzt ist man den verbrauch so
lassen die aufständischen
das wäre nicht so knapp hinter ihm war
mit der örtlich kommt auch hinten auf
[Musik]
kommt nicht schön
gespielt
es ist sehr frustrierend
dass minderjährige vor hannah höchs
politik macht die drei rettungssanitäter
und
stellt manager
hilft ja es ist so dass man habe ihnen
hilft in der betrunkene auch sicherlich
nicht unbedingt dafür dass man so einen
gewissen denn neben eröffnet und marg
moll
und so zu haben griff lichkeiten dass
die angriffe als er sich stellen
ja
der sozialarbeiter michael salvatore
kennt die facetten des
jugendalkoholismus und weiß was in der
szene abgeht
[Musik]
alkohol ist nicht so
effektvoll die linie
der rapper baut dort stammt aus pakistan
ist 17 jährig und träumt von einer
karriere als
profi homo
sendetechnik und das macht uns kommt hat
geburtstag wir brauchen eine geburt
damit zogen
[Musik]
dass man nichts sagen ich bin
alkoholiker werden soll
das ist dass ich so ein tier das sich in
einen esel jene die sich so aus der
jugend der tätige jugendliche
lernen
15-20 doppel kommt durch barbie mir
gerne
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die basler kids bringen sich für eine
party mit ein paar bierchen in gute
laune bei anderes war das anders er
trank versteckt und alleine die flasche
war zu seinem freund geworden
[Musik]
ich denke
einfach
immer weiter vor verdammt ich schmiss
ziel ging sie dass sie an die sache
ist
das schon eine gute zeit sehen wir
bilden die ifa mit
und welche konflikte organ etwa
stromschiene stress ob das
so richtig was liegt für stress um die
macht
[Musik]
je leichter alkoholfrei käuflich ist
desto mehr wird getrunken die kehle
salvadori zeigt uns einen quartierladen
in basel
hier können sich die jugendlichen fast
rund um die uhr mit alkohol eindecken
[Musik]
möchte das vormodell er zum sechster
das konto vor sie sollen die große
filiale und so eigentlich nichts aber es
gibt auch kleine laden und da kommt mit
zum teil schon
ausnahmen
[Musik]
alkohol kann aggressiv machen aber auch
locker und vergnüglich salvatori hat
gegenüber dem alkoholkonsum von
jugendlichen eine pragmatische haltung
hauptgrund sowie nie verstand ist das
ist einfach das gemeinschaftsgefühl
zusammen mit freunden kollegen
gute stimmung das gehört irgendwie dazu
und ich muss auch sagen ich mein vorbild
das sie schon einmal ein stück vom fc
barcelona
das ist legal machen nicht machen und
verwies die zahl der alko pops macht es
leichter es ist eine stewardess mit
christiane staab euro hätte er bis in
der hand mehr weiß wo eine mutter
hat ihr wachstum auch sehr genau wie
viel und wie so oft der jugendlichen
die jugendszene trifft sich neckt sich
hat von und trinkt ganz
selbstverständlich ein paar bierchen
aber anders als bei anderes dienst der
alkohol hier dem sozialen kontakt
[Musik]
die allermeisten jugendlichen schaffen
den vernünftigen umgang mit alkohol
[Musik]
absolventa brauchte war ein
trolley würde heute denn ja also jungen
gold den scheuer
obwohl ich dreh garten zum
finanzmarkt angeschnitten
werden ist sich ein gemütliches
kurz sprach gute freunde
doch wie der fall von anderes zeigt kann
der alkohol einen jugendlichen an den
abgrund führen
die frau
jetzt so als ob die aber denke
werde ich dort so
verdammt sind das jetzt vom heim problem
komme und drückt metro ghana das
vergessen kapital für
dich als oftmals
schnell dass auch zum die richtige wahl
für dicke luft und das ist
ja das war aber möchte aber schon tot
sind es alte tuberkulose
bin ich froh dass jetzt sein ende
und es ist mehr als willkommen anderes
buch heißt der hypnose mit dem neuen
namen auf sich hat das diskutieren jetzt
hat sie damals in dem film hat sie
klartext die wahrheit lieber tot
schließlich wird sie mit
und man kann so und das ist irgendwie
gezeigt dass die englische suite wachsen
immer ganze welt was gott ich nicht auch
wenn sie jetzt die bilder aller
genutzten distanz vor acht jahren
wie soll
sie
erschrocken so das ist so viel gemacht
ich will jetzt nur vom schloss entfernt
die sich wie deine ideen situationen ja
so eine sache
meine sache
sie haben damals sei
sie clean oder auch sehen dass menschen
es behauptet wie clean sind sie wirklich
sie was sie wollen
ja ja das
kann ich das heißt also nicht wie spielt
mit dem c30 nicht das ist
uns ja allen
trinken
und rückfahrt im bus oder sucht uns
hoffentlich passiert und was sind was
sind denn so schlüsselerlebnisse wo sie
wiederum kritik
für den tanker kaufen frühere versucht
dieser
[Musik]
zeit nur über
wasser halten
so
groß
ist einfacher wenn man trinkt also oder
anders gesagt es ist ein schluck
potro was hätte ich auch nichts
motiviert und rufen
also jetzt noch von damals damals hat
mich motiviert das
schaffen dass man die strukturen nach
oben deshalb kann das machen
wofür familie hat sie wenn sind die
ganze woche
ganz
ganz trocken
so
dass ich immer noch witze
machen
lassen
sondern sie tatsächlich schon
seit datenzugang
beziehen sowie dannzumal
was heißt das konkret wie viel
das
ist ja auch dass sie völlig in ordnung
ob sie hatten trotzdem das gefühl
[Musik]
deswegen kopf ganz
herzliches schlüsselerlebnis gab es sie
zum 6
natürlich war nicht nur und das war mir
egal oder der filmisch vor acht jahren
standen
es ist viel passiert sieht er aber unter
anderem eine dritte familie die
grenzen ausloten
möglicherweise die kontrolle verlieren
weg von der alltagsnormalität nur mit
sich alleine sein gefühle die andere es
beim walken sucht
es hat sich viel verändert in seinem
leben
den alkohol teufel den hat er in den
griff gekriegt beiden hilft ihm dabei
dann mach es dann
die sofortige
abschalten schallt vor allem das liefern
schaffen
der sieger darf das
[Musik]
andres hat seinen eigenen umgang mit dem
alkoholkonsum gefunden
[Musik]
ob sie jetzt dass sie die vier wochen
gar nicht trinken also
mit nun alles so
aber das ging also dann gesagt
das musst du dennoch bringt das madrid
zurück das war so groß dass
man muss auch kraft und
motivation das
essen fertig das nicht wird die kassen
könnten
nicht wieder dem alkohol verfallen
anderes hat zwei kleine kinder die geben
ihm orientierung im leben
besuch von der mutter und ihrem zweiten
ehemann zu seinem leiblichen vater hat
anderes schon lange keinen kontakt mehr
[Musik]
der vierjährige jason freut sich wenn
das gros mami kommt bringt sie immer ein
geschenk für ihn mit
für die mutter ist ja so ein anderes wie
verwandelt
[Musik]
im nebenzimmer schläft schießens
schwesterchen josef die vor sechs
monaten auf die welt gekommen ist
anderes wohnt mit seiner frau thea in
einer einfachen dreizimmerwohnung in
zollikofen bei bern
aber wie findet ein junger alkoholiker
eine frau die mit ihm eine familie
gründen will
ja ja das ist schlimm wenn man mit 17
also ist
die kollegen
und die gott und vom disneyland
in verliert kann
sie verantwortet das kind und sogar eine
frage sie was hat das mit wir machen
alles vom ersten moment an bord und
daraus war ich ja mal von zu 100 prozent
abgeschafft wird und das kann man nicht
von jedem einer 20 jährigen behauptet
also
gemacht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
absolut
acht jahre sind vergangen seit wir mit
hygiene salvatore die aufgekratzten
jugendlichen auf diesem platz in basel
gefilmt hatten
gehört also kanton fribourg das gleiche
jetzt demnächst führe ich danke was
wirklich bis bringt war aber die
testkäufe und vor allem alkohol türen
machen wie biete sich geräte ufer metern
priester mit ein wenig verkaufte die
wirtschaft das immer noch so dass man
nicht schon vor acht jahren die haben
immer wieder daher gäbe mittlerem
zuckeranteil schaffte sie auch dass es
so kommt wie eine sprite sozusagen das
gorki that dirt müssen einerseits und
der familie althoff jeden fall ja
[Musik]
verbote und schwarze pädagogik haben
zumindest im falle von anderes wenig
genutzt im heim hatte anderes damals
eine an lehre als landschaftsgärtner
gemacht ein harter beruf der nur einen
bescheidenen verdienst mit sich bringt
enorme freut dass boost auf schafe und
und
derzeit bietet
zusätzlich serie
erzählt mein körper firma
landschaftsgarten
originale gemacht hat und das
ausprobieren
anderes hat großes glück gehabt einen
derart verständnisvollen chef zu finden
familie beruf alles scheint sich nun zum
guten zu wenden
[Musik]
anderes hat wieder boden unter den füßen
weiß für was es sich lohnt zu leben
[Musik]
in einer grube in der es heißt der track
ist das sieht ein am freitag 9 es wird
gelogen weil sie sagt sich ein zwischen
den spitzen trinken und eigentlich sagen
grüne alkoholiker dass gott überhaupt
unter keinen umständen warum schaufelt
sich aus
der familie weil wir angst dass sie das
kann verlieren und mit wissen wir
definitiv
aktivieren die kreis ist es aber nicht
wie hat sie das geschafft aber der
kompass neu ausrichtete im leben was
gibt ihnen kraft und wisla plock
wirtschaft familie natürlich
mit villepin im glauben
dass gebracht hat und der gabe den
erhalt wie wir aktiv sind
also erst montagabend
nummer ist
also die verankerung im boden und was
wir noch unternimmt er die mutter ehec
merkel sie tun können was ist wenn die
kinder mal ich würde sofort positiv
wären ja oder ja
also ich schon nachvollziehen schon mal
versteckt oder stroh vom chef hinweg
oder
denn zur macht werde ich mit meiner
mutter steel.com was es wirklich
etwas glücklich aber berlin nach weil
das
thema so will er da braucht man einen
move taucher zum halten abstand da wirst
du ja schon läuft wie will sie reagieren
wenn es für ein kind eine offenbarung
wiederholen der film zeigt formiert
was hat die motive machen damals zum
tragen als gar
keine kopie
tagsüber durchdenkt yaya touré sei es
besser jetzt keine daten um so
das schlachtross
eigentlich bei mir aber
schon angst dass
das
teil
von dem was sie jetzt
zeigt sich wie wenig zu sagen wie viel
glück ist
also
also da haben sie sich die rückgaben
chefs finden wo gut ist ja mal von einer
zwischenzeit der chef sie getraut sie
ist dass ab der vom schicksal
ja
und ja also ja schon aus dem 26
sind spanien 12 monate vorher an der
quarter in einem zdf bahn komplett
anders so woher eigentlich schon das
wort mit ihm dass er so
wie es jetzt irgendwie alles
zurückzahlen ich finde es irgendwie
schwierig sie so
schlagzeug dazu
was ein ziel wie gross ist klar dass sie
je wieder rückfällig werden oder gibt es
das risiko
ich wünsche ihnen außerdem sind auf wie
das max ende
gut alles gut die andere sprache
das ist fortsetzung folgt sie und mixen
bis heute in der woche wieder und den
habe ich der prominente besuch
das wiesel oder schweizerin vom jahr
[Applaus]
er schlug zudem
[Musik]
die kanzlei bochum ziehen die
mitarbeiter und k von über robbies sich
selbstlos für talkshow derart bevor
heidi gesetzt hat und zum team kürzer
verständlicher frau
maybachstraße in speziellen sich wenn
man im krisengebiet der menschen hilft
um noch herzlich im rat
[Musik]